les entreprises que vous représentez le
g et le f dégâts façon bien souvent au
coeur de nos débats une discussion et
c'est pour ça qu'il était important que
nous vous auditionnons ce matin c'est en
effet un souhait de notre commission de
vous entendre ensemble et non pas comme
à l'accoutumée sur quels sujets précis
mais plutôt sur l'ensemble de deux beaux
actions et les différents points sur
lequel vous êtes régulièrement cité pour
introduire ce des barbes
je dirais que d'un côté vous fournissez
dans le monde entier des services très
apprécié par des milliards d'usagers
dont un certain nombre d'entre nous vous
contribuez aussi chacun au projet au
progrès pardon en facilitant l'accès aux
connaissances et aux savoirs et vous
vous rendez plus aisés les relations
sociales et de l'autre côté vous êtes
régulièrement mises en accusation dans
une diversité de domaines qui marque à
elle seule votre affluent soit votre
domination respect de la vie privée
protection de la propriété
intellectuelle
assèchement du marché publicitaire au
détriment des médias traditionnels
création de bulbul de filtres par un
ciblage toujours plus précis des centres
d'intérêts par des algorithmes pas
toujours transparent comme l'avait très
bien relevé catherine morin desailly en
un mot vous êtes présent dans de
nombreux domaines et qui concerne notre
commission vous comprendrez bien que
votre succès pratiquement sans
équivalent en tout cas dans cette
ampleur dans l'histoire économique
pousse les autorités publiques de tous
les pays à se pencher sur la question de
la régulation
nous avons également pris bonne note des
déclarations des présidents de vos
sociétés qui ont déclaré être conscient
des responsabilités qui pesait sur eux
même si bonne noter que cette prise de
conscience est faite est à la fois et à
chaque fois pardon en réaction un
certain nombre de demandes voire
d'actions judiciaires pour reprendre une
formule célèbre que spider man aurait
emprunté un décret de la convention ne
s'est pas ce spider man à la convention
du 8 mai 1793
de grands pouvoirs viennent de grandes
responsabilités je propose donc chacun
d'entre vous si vous en êtes d'accord
réalise une courte intervention
d'affaires assez synthétique pour
privilégier un format de questions
réponses et une courte intervention
liminaire de 5 à 10 minutes pour nous
préciser la manière dont vous réagissez
face aux craintes et aux interrogations
que suscite aujourd'hui votre place dans
nos sociétés encore renforcée par la
pandémie
je passerai ensuite la parole bien sûr
ou sénatrice et aux sénateurs en
commençant par david assouline pour
évoquer plus spécifiquement la question
des droits voisins et des droits voisins
des éditeurs et des agences de presse je
vous propose j'ai pas eu de tirage au
sort mais je pense que ça ne posera
aucun problème de commencer par monsieur
missoffe de 2 de google qui ensuite ne
se battait style pour facebook
andré de rester dans ce créneau de 5 à
10 minutes parce que il y a je n'en
doute pas de nombreuses questions de la
part des sénateurs et des sénatrices
monsieur monsieur le président merci
pour eux c'est mon introduction
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci de nous recevoir aujourd'hui merci
pour cette opportunité d'échangé nous
savons combien à votre commission et le
sénat est engagée sur l'ensemble des
questions touchant au numérique qui vous
l'avez évoqué cette liste est longue
il nous a semblé très important avec
benoît tabaka devenir aujourd'hui
répondre de vive voix à toutes les
interrogations que vous pouvez avoir sur
les différents sujets dont nous voulons
parler aujourd'hui
alors peut-être juste quelques mots
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
sur les sujets de la culture en
particulier
je tenais à vous redire au nom des 1200
collaborateurs de google en france
combien nous nous sommes mobilisés pour
affronter la crise sanitaire en
contribuant dans tous les territoires à
l'information des français et à leur
appropriation des outils du numérique
dont on a vu combien on en avait besoin
dans ces mois difficiles
en effet nous sommes absolument
convaincus vous le rappeliez que la
réussite n'est pas celle de la
technologie là
réussite passe par celle des femmes et
des hommes qui savent s'approprier cette
technologie et nous avons donc fait de
la formation aux outils du numérique
dans les territoires une priorité avec
300 partenaires locaux les chambres de
commerce les agences pour l'emploi
les chambres de métiers d'artisanat les
offices du tourisme les universités nous
avons été dans plus de 270 villes en
france pour former plus de 600000
personnes depuis 2012 c'est un
engagement très important pour nous et
c'est vrai pour les utilisateurs au
quotidien comme pour les pme les
entreprises pour vraiment s'approprier
ces outils pour entrer dans le coeur du
sujet sur les sujets liés à la culture
en france
nous savons ce que nous devons à
l'exception culturelle française
nous sommes fiers de contribuer à son
rayonnement suivre et à l'international
puisque la moitié du temps de visionnage
des créations françaises sur youtube se
fait aujourd'hui à l'étranger c'est vrai
en france nous avons contribué à mettre
en contact un certain nombre d'acteurs
de la vie culturelle avec des nouvelles
audiences
pour prendre l'exemple d'arte et qui a
pu conquérir de nouveaux publics
l'âge moyen du téléspectateurs d'arte et
sur youtube et de 35 ans contre 50 ans
sur le site ou 63 ans à l'antenne
ils ont presque 2 millions d'abonnés
aujourd'hui sur la chaîne on voit
combien ces nouveaux moyens ont permis
de continuer à garder le lien avec ces
nouvelles audiences mais nous savons
aussi vous le rappeliez combien le
numérique a bouleversé la culture
l'équilibré à trouver entre le secteur
culturel et le secteur du numérique
dépasse bien sûr notre seule entreprise
mais pour ce qui est de google nous
avons toujours eu à coeur de comprendre
les enjeux des coûts télé
inquiétude et à chaque fois de nous
mobiliser pour trouver des solutions
google est aujourd'hui une entreprise
internationale
c'est une entreprise multi local qui est
implémenté en france depuis 18 ans et
qui a su donner de plus en plus
d'autonomie aux équipes dans chaque pays
afin de répondre à des enjeux locaux
spécifiques
j'ai rejoint google il ya 15 ans et j'ai
vraiment pu voir cette évolution et en
particulier depuis quatre ans en france
où j'ai pris mes responsabilités
combien nous avions cette autonomie pour
répondre à ces enjeux spécifiques
cela nous a permis de travailler en
étroite collaboration avec les acteurs
de la culture sont grandes déclarations
nous avançons pas à pas cela prend du
temps
nous sommes pleinement conscients et
cela nécessite de multiplier des
relations sereines construite et
pragmatique
nous avançons et nous sommes fiers de
nous différencier sur ce point là avant
de terminer je vais juste peut être
partagé trois exemples qui illustrent
cet engagement je vais vous parler
brièvement de ce que nous avons fait sur
la valorisation du patrimoine de la
protection du droit d'auteur et bien sûr
parler de la question des éditeurs et
des agences de presse dans le cadre des
droits voisins
alors cet engagement pour la
valorisation du patrimoine nous y
contribuons en france avec google art et
culture qui depuis sa création 2011
installer une équipe d'une trentaine de
personnes qui est basé en france et qui
développe des solutions qui permettent
d'explorer en ligne l'art l'histoire et
les merveilles du monde
vous pourrez aller du plafond de ces
gars-là l'opéra garnier en passant par
la galerie des glaces du château de
versailles
nous avons numérisé des kilomètres
carrés de boiseries et l'espace ou enfin
aller dans l'ain dans la grotte chauvet
je vous invite par exemple à vous
immerger dans le travail de l'oeuvre de
kandinsky avec une expérience
entièrement numérique que nous avions
coproduite avec le centre pompidou
quand les musées a été fermé
cela passe
si par un engagement pour la protection
du droit d'auteur depuis plus de dix ans
nous avons su nouer des accords avec la
sacem avec la ss et des avec la scam
pour l' usage de leurs protégés et puis
il ya quelques semaines nous avons noué
un partenariat très important avec la
dea gp et avec l'acef pour les dix
prochaines années
ce programme inclut une licence pour
l'utilisation en france des oeuvres de
leur répertoire et plus ne va plus loin
avec un fonds pour les artistes membres
qui est destiné à soutenir et rémunérer
les auteurs des arts graphiques
plastique et photographiques
le ministère de la culture nous a
félicité de cette étape la protection du
droit d'auteur c'est aussi la lutte
contre le piratage
youtube a développé dès 2007 un outil
nommé compte entre 10 qui fait référence
en matière de reconnaissance automatisée
de contenu et de lutte contre le pari
d'un piratage
nous avons investi à ce jour plus de 100
millions de dollars dans le
développement de compte entre 10 nous
sommes en période de l'euro vous pouvez
imaginer qu'à chaque fois qu'un but est
marqué par telle ou telle équipe il ya
une tentation pas quelqu'un de prendre
un extrait de cette vidéo la de la
mettre sur youtube en temps réel nous
recevons le flux depuis les ayants droit
et ces vidéos ne vont pas sur youtube et
sont enlevées directement car nous avons
l'empreinte de cette vidéo qui permet
d'être enlevées se la jouer un rôle
considérable dans la protection du droit
d'auteur et c'est un des outils dont
nous sommes le plus fiers
et puis en france on a été plus loin sur
ce sujet là avec la signature en 2017
d'un accord avec l'association de lutte
contre la piraterie audiovisuelle alpa
sous l'égide du cnc pour lutter plus
efficacement contre le piratage en ligne
ce qui nous a permis d'avoir
l'intégralité du catalogue de gaumont et
et d'autres pour protéger encore mieux
les différentes oeuvres
et puis pour terminer quelques mots sur
notre engagement dans le soutien aux
éditeurs et aux agences de presse
dans le cadre fixé par la loi sur le
droit voisin monsieur le président vous
rappeliez des changements très
importante que vit ce groupe est là
l'importance pour nous de nous engager
sur ce point là alors d'abord ses
échanges avec le secteur de la presse
ont démarré en temps puisqu'il y a près
de dix ans en 2013 le fond google était
il faut le rappeler
au plan mondial le premier à signer un
accord entre acteurs du numérique et le
secteur de la presse
au total nous avons versé plus de 85
millions d'euros aux éditeurs à travers
ses différents programmes et nous sommes
encore engagés aujourd'hui dans
l'accompagnement de leur transformation
numérique en juillet 2019
la france a été le premier pays à
transposer la loi sur le droit voisin au
profit des éditeurs et des agences de
presse
google a été la première entreprise en
gaz est engagée dans ces discussions
il nous sommes les premiers à avoir pu
trouver un accord avec l'accord iv qui
avaient été annoncées auprès des 295
titre certifié ipg de la figue et cet
accord s'est fait avec une répartition
transparente objectif et non
discriminante est vraiment unique
une implémentation française alors oui
nous l'avons entendu lors des récentes
auditions nous aurions sûrement pour
faire mieux et différemment sur un
certain nombre de points
je ne vais pas refaire le match
aujourd'hui mais par contre je tenais à
vous redire solennellement devant vous
notre engagement
google reconnaît les droits voisins et
je suis déterminé à trouver une solution
nous avons eu plus de 200 réunions avec
des éditeurs de presse avec des agences
de presse et nous continuerons à
travailler pour arriver à ces solutions
c'est cet objectif qui nous a animés
depuis mars 2020 et nous avons récemment
annoncé étendre notre offre a davantage
d'acteurs de presse au delà de la presse
ipg et nous avons aussi entendu les
inquiétudes ici et là sur le rapport de
confiance et donc nous avons aussi
annoncé vouloir investir en rétablissant
cette confiance et partageant les
données avec un tiers de confiance
bref sur chacun de ces sujets nous les
prenons très au sérieux nous écoutons
les inquiétudes et nous travaillons à
trouver des solutions pour avancer avec
des partenariats qui nous permettent
nous en sommes convaincus d'avancé
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
tenais à nouveau personnellement à vous
remercier de votre habitation
aujourd'hui nous avons très à coeur de
prendre en compte l'exception culturelle
française et de travailler main dans la
main avec les acteurs de la culture
je vous remercie pour votre écoute et je
suis
disposition pour répondre à toutes les
questions si monsieur battisti merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs déjà je voudrais dire que je
suis ravi d'être ici avec vous quand
j'étais étudiant ma décision préféré du
conseil constitutionnel concerne la
liberté d'association
le sénat en son temps 71 avait porté et
défendu et je pense que ça montre la
constance cas de l'engagement de sept
chambres sur des sujets de société et
incertain certains approche des libertés
publiques que j'ai toujours trouvé
intéressante et qui se manifeste encore
aujourd'hui dans le numérique
j'ai pu le constater l'année dernière
dans nos discussions sur la ppl d'itavia
et sur bien d'autres sujets je suis
aussi ravi de m'adresser aussi
indirectement françaises et aux français
puisqu'il nous regarde
on pourra aussi répond directement aux
interrogations vous l'avez relevé
monsieur président qui se posent à notre
sujet en tant qu' une utilisatrice
utilisateurs de nos services facebook en
france c'est pas quelque chose de
désincarné nous sommes ici présent je
vous dire quelques mots
je précise qu'en fonction des questions
à peu près une décennie de présence
1 c'est un laboratoire de recherche en
intelligence artificielle le plus grand
laboratoire de recherche de facebook en
dehors des états unis dont le leadership
d'ailleurs est principalement français
donc ce qui marque aussi l'excellence de
notre pays dans en ces domaines et des
recherches qui sont tout à fait
fondamentale on prend en reparler sur la
détection d'image l'algorithme est aussi
dans le domaine du handicap dans dans
beaucoup de domaines en tout cas c'est
un laboratoire extrêmement actif à peu
près une centaine de chercheurs
aujourd'hui donc il ya
extraordinairement grandi c'est aussi un
enracinement dans le tissu associatif on
a un fond pour civisme en ligne avec
beaucoup d'associations pourra y revenir
pour tout ce qui concerne les questions
on en parle en ce moment de cyber
harcèlement des usages responsables du
numérique dans le domaine culturel de
plus en plus etc etc et la question
culturelle qui qui vous intéressent
alors bien sûr nous sommes en discussion
là aussi j'imagine qu'on y reviendra sur
les amis
on a de l'article 17 avec certain nombre
d'acteurs et pour ce qui concerne les
éditeurs de presse nous sommes en
discussion depuis l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi ne sais pas qui a décroché son
téléphone le premier mais bon là n'est
pas la question
ce qui compte c'est d'y arriver ça prend
un peu plus de temps parce qu'évidemment
les débats passionnés les litiges
d'hiver on fait que nos interlocuteurs
parfois voilà évidemment avancé sur deux
fronts en même temps mais le ciel se
dégageant veut dire des accords ont pu
être trouvé des accords seront trouvées
il faut rester confiant dans ces
domaines pendant la crise sanitaire si
cela vous intéresse pas c'est vrai ces
points mais on a beaucoup de travail en
trois coloris sont avec le sii j'ai
notamment pour l'information auprès des
populations pour leur apporter des ouïes
des informations fiables en matière
sanitaire sur la vaccination très
récemment aussi dans la lutte contre
l'effet que news qui a été
particulièrement agressive pour ce qui
concerne bien entendu la sûreté de nos
concitoyens et enfin dernier point est
ce que je veux pas être trop long alors
en tant que fans de marvel jeu vraiment
je n'aurais jamais cru qu'au sénat on
puisse citer spider man mais j'en suis
donc d'autant plus ravi d'être sénat
aujourd'hui
mais si une fois ce qu on a beaucoup
entendu mais là elle à elle a un sens et
qu'on entend c'est donc dans nos
entreprises ce que vous imaginez bien
que voilà vu la moyenne d'âge tout le
monde et fans de marvel on va dire elle
a un sens parce qu'elle en finale ans
que l'oncle de spider-man veut dire à
spider man c'est que la responsabilité
c'est que quand on peut faire quelque
chose de positif on doit le faire
c'est un principe d'action impérative
dirais quand et c'est un cheminement
j'en veux dire on arrive à un âge où un
tournant dans lequel ces entreprises
notre entreprise doivent prendre des
décisions en la matière soit on va vers
un chemin de responsabilité qui passe
par de la régulation mais pas que et
c'est pour ça qu'on peut être en soutien
du dr ça on en parlera du dma ou
d'autres dispositions nationales parce
qu'il faut de la responsabilité et de la
transparence soit on ne le fait pas et
hier pas de confiance
les gens se détourneront de nous je le
pense et j'aime bien dire qu'il n'ya pas
de compagnies aériennes son passage et
donc a pas de réseau social sans
utilisatrices utilisateurs
nous en sommes là après plus de 15 ans
d'existence
et oui on aura bien sûr par des
désaccords sur la régulation comment
elle se fait des désaccords petit des
accords plus grand mais en tout cas
c'est un chemin sur lequel nous sommes
collectivement engagés donc on va y
travailler ensemble toujours merci merci
commencer les questions bonheur parole
d'abord à david assouline qui ait été
rapporteur de la ppl seraient les droits
voisins se souvient évidemment tous ici
et ensuite michel logique que rapporteur
pour avis des crédits budgétaires
david merci monsieur le président j'ai
j'ai écouté attentivement aux invités on
doit d'abord noter que le ton a changé
notamment j'étais coupant après l'avoir
entendu dans un bureau ici de façon
publique subit sauf google dire qu'elle
vous reconnaissez les droits voisins
pour les éditeurs de presse
vous conviendrez que ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas et qu au lendemain de
l'adoption de la loi que j'ai initié qui
a fait du d'éditer des deux chambres sur
les droits voisins
le président de google news qui était
venu rencontrer un cycle ministre nous
avait signifié que ce n'était pas du
tout leur culture ni votre appréciation
de ce qui était juste vous étiez dans
l'idée jusqu'à présent de pouvoir aider
la presse de définir ce que vous pouviez
donner pour aider la presse et la
liberté d'expression mais qu'en aucun
cas c'était un droit des éditeurs et une
loi à laquelle vous deviez vous à ce
sujet tient donc ça c'est un grand
progrès sur le fou
ceci dit je vous pose une question très
direct quand on voit depuis un
particulièrement le début de la pandémie
pour différentes raisons les bénéfices
et les sommes colossales que vous pouvez
accumuler
quelle que soit la situation puisque
dans une crise il ya plutôt tendance à
s'appauvrir
pour la grande majorité pensez vous
vraiment même si je n'ai pas la somme
d'un accord secret d'ailleurs c'est ça
le problème que vous avez pu passer avec
une petite partie de la presse française
sont ridicules c'est à dire que c'est à
peu près ce que la france devrait avoir
par rapport à vos engagements mondiaux
d'il ya près de deux ans vous avez dit
on va donner un milliard à la presse
dans le monde
c'est pas terrible hein vu les sommes en
jeu la somme française correspond à une
division de ses 1 milliard à hauteur de
la population française vous imaginez
donc le problème
au delà de la somme c'est qui est une
règle est que l'ensemble de la presse
puisse puisse vraiment bénéficié du fait
que l'essentiel de la publicité a migré
vers le net et donc vers vous or c'était
la base du financement de la presse en
france et que vous exploitez des
contenus d'information qui attire
d'ailleurs donc du monde vers votre
plateforme est donc attire la publicité
sont créés cette information qui coûte
cher pour qu'elle soit fiable c'est
parce qu'à une presse et des
journalistes et des reporters sur des
théâtres de guerre par exemple que l'on
peut se dire qu'il ya une information
qui remonte
mais elle coûte donc ma première
question c'est la somme la deuxième très
concrète comment réagissez-vous à
l'initiative que je trouve bonne que je
soutiens en tous les cas personnellement
prise par deux syndicats professionnels
représentant les sites d'information et
de presse spécialisée la fen ps et le
syndicat de la presse d'information
indépendante en ligne qui ont rejoint
l'initiative du syndicat des éditeurs de
la presse magazine
ça fait du monde pour créer un organisme
de gestion collective dédiée avec le
soutien de la sacem comme support est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est pas mieux même
pour vous d'avoir un interlocuteur qui
regroupe et qui connaît le métier on va
dire est qu'ils soient face à vous pour
négocier et redistribuer ses droits je
veux je veux finir en étayant mon propos
sur l'ampleur de ce que l'on attend de
vous et 2019 google a été condamné à 500
millions d'amande pour fraude fiscale à
graver des blanchiment en bande
organisée de fraude fiscale aggravé et
465 millions d'euros de rattrapage
impôts payés à l'administration fiscale
heureusement depuis le 1er janvier 2001
vous avez annoncé cesser d'exploiter des
mécanismes d'optimisation fiscale en
europe
est ce que google va payer désormais ses
impôts dans les pays où il exerce ses
activités
lors du dernier
j'essaie une taxe internationale disant
à fonctionner les multinationales qui
réalisent des bénéfices sans les
déclarer auprès des services fiscaux du
pays étrangers où se trouve pourtant les
clients et les consommateurs a été
décidé des sept puissances mondiales se
sont mises d'accord sur un taux d'impôt
minimale mondiale sur ces sociétés d'au
moins 15%
qu'en pensez vous et ça c'est l'ensemble
des interlocuteurs pour ne pas être long
je ne pas poser de questions à facebook
à part celle où aller ce sont concernés
deux collègues le front mais comme je me
suis concentré sur la question des
droits voisins
c'était bien entendu google principal
interlocuteur
en conclusion vraiment on peut faire fi
du passé
si vous reconnaissez le droit voisin
reconnaissez le jusqu'au bout et traiter
l'ensemble de la presse française sans
chercher à la diviser je sais que c'est
compliqué pour évaluer exactement les
sommes comment ces calculs etc mais
mettez-y de la bonne volonté je pense
qu'il y va de votre image mais liv a su
surtout de la démocratie il faut
aujourd'hui aider la presse et son
pluralisme qui en danger merci
j'ai oublié de dire j'ai dit que le
sénateur assouline était le rapporteur
de la ppl il en était aussi l'auteur je
corrige le petit omission michel logis
merci monsieur le président je savais
bien sûr nos invités c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un rôle
primordial prédominant dans la société
dans laquelle nous vivons
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure qu'il ya
des accords d avancer oui mais ce que je
regrette c'est que il a fallu que même
l'autorité de la concurrence tape du
poing sur la table pour qu'enfin on
puisse avoir des négociations parce que
jusqu'à présent alors chaleureux l'un de
vous a parlé le super u qui le premier a
décroché son téléphone en tout cas moi
ce que j'ai constaté c'est que vous avez
profité de la division finalement des
éditeurs de presse des agences de presse
pour bien ne prendre aucune décision sur
le président vous a parlé tout à l'heure
de la création du fonds oui mais un fond
c'est vous qui décidez la somme qui a
sur le fond c'est vous qui a abondé
alors que ce que diront que le fonds de
fonds n'était pas là david assouline l'a
rappelé nous nous souhaitions bien sûr
que les éditeurs puissent se retrouver
retrouvez finalement l'investissement
qui est l'honneur qui est le leur
alors je voudrais juste vous poser
quelques questions bien précises
j'ai eu la possibilité de vous
rencontrer les représentants de google
dans le bureau du président avec david
assouline
mais pendant j'ai jamais entendu
facebook alors j'aimerais connaître un
petit peu la position de facebook est
resté très discret jusqu'à présent
savait qu'en france a beau content dé
google mais pas beaucoup facebook dont
je vais la voir la position officielle
de facebook face à la situation
on a parlé des éditeurs mais il ya aussi
un problème avec les agences de presse
et c'est vrai que la parution de loi
c'était bien sur les i coeur et les
agences de presse dont je veux savoir
aujourd'hui
ouais tu es ce que vous avez tous des
négociations avec les agences de presse
et notamment avec l' agence
france-presse
ensuite je voudrais aussi
connaître puisque des choses évoluent
aussi dans d'autres pays est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un petit peu le
contenu du compromis qui était signée en
australie par facebook etc a mis fin à
la crise qui agite ce pays
et puis j'aime aussi puisque on allait
dans les autres pays que nous fassions
petit point aussi avec se passe dans les
autres pays européens
je vous remercie voilà première série de
questions très précises une en d2 d'y
répondre et puis il ya d'autres
sénateurs qui interviendront par la
suite j'ai envie de commencer sur les
quelques éléments
le sénateur d'abord tout d'abord merci
pour vos mots d'encouragement c'est en
effet une situation difficile sur lequel
nous avons débroussailler le terrain
avec un certain nombre de ces
discussions
vous évoquez le fait qu'en effet google
est très associée à ce sujet sur le
droit voisin alors que ce n'est pas
évidemment lié à google c'est lié à
internet en général je prends ce sujet
plutôt comme une fierté sur le fait que
nous sommes sur le terrain avec ces
discussions et que nous le prenons très
au sérieux à travers cet engagement
je suis très aligné en tant que
représentants de google et en tant que
citoyen évidemment sur le rôle de la
presse sur le rôle de journalisme des
agences de presse dans le débat
démocratique et vous évoquez les
montants sont importants et j'aimerais
vraiment revenir sur notre engagement
sur trois grandes étapes le premier
évidemment ces six contrats de licence
dans le cadre du droit voisin et je
réponds aussi à votre question le fonds
dont je parlais ses 85 millions avait
été fait sous l'égide du président de la
république françois hollande à l'époque
en 2013 c'était un fonds et c'était
cette décision là la décision a été
prise en france à travers la
transposition de la directive européenne
d'avoir cette loi et ce n'est pas
enfoncé par google qui décident dé tel
ou tel et c'est bien de coeur de cet
accord cadre avec l'information de la
presse générale puisque les 295 titre
reçoivent ce montant là de façon
transparente et c'est pas google qui
décident tel ou tel engagement
donc il ya cet engagement qui est dans
le cadre ce contrat de licence dans le
cadre des droits voisins et qui est
construit sur la valeur que tire google
de ces contenus et puis évidemment il
faut aller plus loin puisque
entendant tu en parles sont importants
et c'est pour ça que nous nous sommes
engagés sur un deuxième sujet et sur
lequel nous continuons à travailler qui
est le sujet de la publicité on en
parlait tout à l'heure
peut-être pour partager un chiffre qui
est important mais dès 1000m 18 si on
prend une année
orco vide c'est 14 milliards de dollars
qui ont été partagés dans le partage de
la revenu sur la publicité une grande
partie des revenus publicitaires qui
sont attribués à google sont
redistribués aux éditeurs de presse est
vrai sur youtube
c'est vrai sur les sites des éditeurs de
presse et sur lequel nous contribuons
avancé sur la publicité mais c'est un
élément important sur lequel nous
travaillons
et puis le troisième sujet de plus en
plus on voit cette piste est de plus en
plus et ce particulièrement importante
c'est le sujet des abonnements qui
permettent aujourd'hui on le voit un
certain nombre de journaux devenir
rentable et on a travaillé sur un
certain nombre de programmes pour
enlever les flexions pour investir sur
ce sujet avec la conviction que ça va
être un pilier très important on a fait
un premier pilote avec le monde et qui
on a partagé ce chiffre que quasiment
40% de ces nouveaux abonnements venait
de ce programme on a réussi à rajouter
40% d'abonnement numérique en plus et la
conviction qu'on avait avant c'est donc
pour répondre à votre question nous
prenons ce sujet au sérieux
c'est vrai dans le cadre du respect des
droits voisins mais c'est vrai en avant
plus loin avec les montants la publicité
et tout ce que nous faisons pour
investir sur cet écosystème
et c'est vrai avec les sujets des
abonnements et c'est vrai sur un certain
nombre de points on continuera à
travailler sur des fonds pour essayer de
continuer à innover sur des nouvelles
pistes certain nombre des projets qui
ont été faits vivent encore ont permis
de faire des tests pour un certain
nombre d'éditeurs de presse si on a la
conviction que c'est aussi un moment où
il faut tester un certain nombre
d'éléments et peut-être benoît tabaka
sur la question spécifique sur la
fiscalité
effectivement pour répondre à ce
sénateur assouline sera question la
fiscalité vous l'avez rappelé on a eu
énormément de débats discussions avec
l'administration fiscale pendant des
années il ya eu des contentieux perdu
gagner à la fin ça s'est soldé par un
accord avec l'administration fiscale qui
a résolu la question du passé sur la
question du présent vous le savez
une taxe celle-ci numérique a été votée
et entre en vigueur le 1er janvier 2019
et ont la taille donc tous les ans on
paye la taxe soit services numériques et
pour nous cette taxe et on est
complètement dans la logique du miz de
l'économie qui est de dire que c'est une
taxe qui doit derrière aboutir à une
réforme fiscale
et c'est vrai que cette réforme fiscale
qui a été marqué fortement par une
avancée assez notable avec le g7 est
quelque chose qu'on soutient depuis 2012
on demande est régulièrement
publiquement en participant aux
discussions de ces deux pour faire
avancer sa traitement fiscal parce qu'on
est con la conscience qu'aujourd'hui le
numérique a mis en avant que un certain
nombre de dispositifs fiscaux qui avait
établi on va dire il ya 20 ou 30 ans ne
peuvent plus fonctionner la même manière
donc on est complètement aligné sur
l'objectif d'avoir une réforme fiscale
des multinationales
on est complètement aligné sur l'idée
qu'il faut sans doute se poser la
question de savoir comment est
redistribué l'impôt puisque aujourd'hui
nous 82% notre impôt que l'on paye il
est versé aux états unis et donc la
question est légitime de savoir est-ce
que ce montant-là d'impôts payés aux
états unis ou dans les autres
territoires doit être redistribué
autrement donc on est complètement
aligné sur l'idée qu'il faut aboutir là
dessus et aboutir rapidement
et tu voulais dire un mot sur les
agences de presse pré poncet prologis
deux éléments sur les agences de presse
premier c'est que nous avons signé un
accord déjà avec writer nous prenons ce
sujet au sérieux nous travaillons avec
elle sur les sujets liés avec les
agences de presse en france nous avons
eu un certain nombre de discussions avec
des agences de presse
est il une en particulier les
discussions avancent et du nouveau
mobilise toutes les équipes pour arriver
je l'espère à trouver un accord
rapidement solis est il de la création
d'un organisme de gestion collective je
m pendu
nous avons vu le l'annoncent évidemment
à partir du moment où on est déterminé à
trouver une solution et qu'on est à
l'écouté
écoutez donc si c'est le choix que font
un certain nombre de groupes et qui
pense que c'est la meilleure solution
nous les rencontrerons et nous ferons en
sorte d'avancer sur ces solutions
c'est prématuré on les a pas encore
rencontré donc je vous donne des
éléments mais de nouveaux s'inscrit dans
une démarche pour trouver la solution le
plus rapidement possible merci micro
parce que nous sommes si vous pouvez
préciser dans votre réponse sur les
agences de presse qu votre position vous
reconnaissez bien que les bases des
agences de presse
rentre bien dans le champ du droit
voisin que vous acceptez nous afin de
nous et nous avons eu des discussions
avec les agences de presse nous
reconnaissions évidemment les
publications presse des agences de
presse et sur ce montant là nous avons
ces discussions monsieur battesti ou
facebook bien sûr rapidement sur la
question de la négociation collective
il va sans dire qu'on négocie avec
toutes entités ou groupement qui se
présente à nous je comprends que de
l'autre côté du miroir rien certains
éditeurs qui souhaitent négocier
collectivement et aussi individuellement
avec les entreprises donc et si on veut
garder voilà un cadre qui permette à
chacun d'eux de négocier la meilleure
façon possible mais sinon j'ai pas
d'autres commentaires sur la création
d'un nouvel organisme
c'est comme la fusion entre l'hadopi et
le csa on travaille déjà avec les 2,6
sacré l'art comme tant mieux voilà donc
on est dans un certain sens historique
qui pour moi ne suscite pas plus de deux
commentaires la question de de la presse
aussi pourrait revenir nous concernant
et pour être très clair je suis navré si
on a été discret mais c'était pas
vraiment volontaire
on est déjà des des relations j'ai avant
l'entrée en vigueur du droit voisin on a
eu beaucoup de relations avec le secteur
pour ce qui est de l'acquisition de
nouveaux abonnés et je vais y venir
c'est à dire un programme
d'accompagnement permettant quand même
aux éditeurs de toucher notamment des
cibles plus jeunes qui ont vocation à
à s'abonner aux journaux je pense qu'on
souhaite tous ici que les jeunes
bénéficient d'une information de qualité
et ensuite donc est entrée en vigueur la
loi sur les droits voisins
c'est assez simple en fait je pense
pourquoi parce que simplement on a
annoncé quand la loi est entrée en
vigueur qu'on allait lancer un nouveau
produit dédié la news si on peut dire
donc c'est une section à l'intérieur de
facebook est déjà un produit qui existe
aux états unis qui existe en allemagne
qui existent au royaume uni il me semble
et donc qui vise à quoi s'emploie à
rémunérer le contenu des éditeurs qui se
trouveront dans cette section facebook
news qui présente plusieurs intérêts
pour l'utilisateur puisque c'est un
accès facile à de l'information de
qualité on reparlera peut-être des faits
qui nous deux c'est quand même important
et donc à l'intérieur mais de ce produit
les contenus seront rémunérés pour
répondre à votre question
voilà ça concerne bien sûr le droit
voisin mais pas qu'eux à la limite
parce que le droit voisin c'est une
réponse juridique un problème
particulier qui fait partie d'un
dispositif visant à assurer ces
transferts de valeur mais rien n'empêche
quelque part d'avoir d'autres mécanismes
de transfert de valeur est aujourd'hui
la question qui est posée aussi c'est
celle de finalement comment on migre
vers le numérique et la presse vis de la
publicité en ligne de l'abonnement bon
l'abonnement doit s'accroître et aussi
la publicité en ligne doit s'accroître
aussi du côté des éditeurs simplement
objectivement de ce que je comprends
c'est compliqué c'est assez inégal et
aussi j'attire l'attention du
législateur sur un certain nombre de
débats juridiques qui concerne les
cookies et autres dispositifs de
publicité en ligne au niveau européen et
national qui viennent quelque part un
peu il faut trouver les équilibres mais
un peu contrarié ses ambitions en
matière de publicité en ligne et donc
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
ces discussions dans laquelle on est sûr
nous nous sommes impliqués parce que
spontanément se tournent vers nous dès
qu'on parle de lui citer en ligne mais
ça concerne aussi ce secteur est tout
autre secteur économique qui vit de la
publicité en ligne et de la publicité en
ligne
c'est pas un mot tabou ciblées voilà ici
parce que c'est une publicité qui a de
la valeur et donc il peut générer de la
valeur pour
aussi les éditeurs de presse donc c'est
un chemin mais sur lequel je pense
il convient d'attirer votre attention
donc négociation gelée disent poursuivre
voilà on n'a pas eu de problème de
litige juridique ça nous arrive dans la
voir sur d'autres sujets il n'a échappé
à personne mais pour ce qui concerne
l'autorité de la concurrence dans ce cas
cela ne nous concerne en rien
voilà donc les négociations continuent
on n'a pas eu de problème avec
l'autorité sur ce point précis
simplement évidemment ça vous l'imaginez
les ressources humaines et et l'hiver
sont parfois limités donc ça va
forcément peut-être un peu ralenti ces
processus mais comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure
voilà le tout c'est d'y arriver on va on
va y arriver dès cette année je vais
très confiant je veux pas oublier
l'australie
l'australie c'est je pense une situation
particulière très différente de la
france dans lequel en plus l'entreprise
de monsieur murdoch elle joue un rôle
évidemment prépondérant on part d'une
situation peut-être il n'y avait rien et
donc il a fallu peut-être créer je
dirais une sorte d'électrochoc juridique
visant à provoquer c'est ces
rapprochements
là où facebook a été en désaccord ce que
ce désaccord s'est manifesté je vais pas
le cacher c'est sur l'extraordinaire je
dirais rigidité d'une loi qui ne tenait
pas compte des apports ou des accords
existants avec le secteur qui nous
disaient vous devez faire ça mais vous
pouvez pas faire ça ça a posé une
situation assez tendue
on peut le regretter parce que c'est
vraiment pas je dirais le moi j'ai pas
mémoire d'un autre exemple et j'aimerais
pas personnellement vivre une telle
situation
en tout cas l'important c'est qu'un
accord a été trouvé qui vise à amender
la loi dans un sens qui tient compte
je dirais des actions et les apports de
valeur déjà établi pour la presse
australienne
et donc voilà les choses je dirais aux
avancées mais la leçon que j'en tire
c'est que
il faut il faut jamais en arriver là
c'est forcément un constat d'échec et
j'ai al'inverse moi je trouve qu'en
europe et particulièrement en france et
je terminerai sur ce point on a il ya un
côté précurseur dans ce domaine comme
dans d'autres et je pense quand même que
notre entreprise s'inscrit dans ce côté
précurseur c'est à dire dans une
démarche de dialogue comme juste et pas
toujours facile il ne s'agit pas
aujourd'hui de dire que tout va bien
tout est facile mais en tout cas qui est
toujours je pense francs mais cordial et
qui permet d'avancer puisque finalement
voilà les choses se font
et j'ai pas de doute quelques elles se
feront dans ces domaines si vous avez
d'autres questions sur votre disposition
d'un surcoût justement vous allez avoir
d'autres questions mais après même après
il est vide a suivi michel logique ont
bien sûr de reprendre la parole par la
suite je vais donner la parole par un
représentant par groupe pour commencer
céline boulay sp rogner républicain
merci monsieur le président on apprend
que la première question qui concerne la
propagation des fausses d'information et
des théories du complot est le cas des
antilles vat notamment pour parler d'un
sujet d'actualité
donc les réseaux sociaux ont pu
contribuer à renforcer les biais
cognitif qui sont à l'origine de
l'adhésion à différentes théories
complotistes facebook a réalisé des
progrès appréciables en renvoyant à
décide de fact checking et en insérant
des avertissements sous les publications
les plus douteuses
de manière générale et en particulier
face à la montée en puissance des
antilles vax ou faudrait-il situer la
limite entre préservation de la liberté
d'expression et politiques de santé
publique
une deuxième question concerne les
mesures prises pour assurer la bonne
tenue des prochaines élections
je pense notamment aux polémiques qui
ont été a fait rentrer sans revenir sur
les différents épisodes de la séquence
électorale de 2016-2017
les réseaux sociaux ont été accusés
d'avoir influencé les campagnes
électorales sur différents continents et
dans la perspective des différents
scrutins en europe notamment la france
et l'allemagne
quelles mesures sont actuellement prises
en matière de contrôle des interférences
qu'elle soit nas
donald ou étrangères et enfin une
troisième question qui concerne le
cyberharcèlement puisque nous sommes
actifs dans une des mieux dans une
mission d'information et d'évaluation
actuellement sur ce problème qui est
qu'il est très difficile d'enrayer et
moi j'ai une théorie je pense qu'il
faudrait absolument simplifiée entre
autres les conditions d'utilisation pour
les mineurs et les rendre plus
accessibles
on sait maintenant que les binaires sont
de plus en plus jeunes à ouvrir des
comptes notamment sur facebook et je
pense que les conditions d'utilisation
ne sent pas assez accessible j'aurais
aimé avoir votre point de vue là dessus
je vous remercie
sylvie robert merci monsieur le
président bonjour messieurs à mon
initiative avec le soutien de mes
collègues que je remercie encore ce avec
l'article 2 1 a été introduit donc dans
le pg l audiovisuel je fais court ils
avaient pour objectif c'est une histoire
qui remonte à la lkp 2016 parce qu'on
avait déjà j'avais déjà commencé avec
eux mes collègues à travailler sur ce
sujet a créé un système de gestion
collective étendue pour les les auteurs
d'oeuvres graphiques auto graphiques et
plastiques et donc comme je disais c'est
une histoire qui remonte à quelques
années quelques jours ou quelques
semaines après ce vote je découvre avec
bonheur
vous en avez parlé que vous avez annoncé
la signature d'un accord avec l'adagp
et là ça y est donc ma question va être
très simple puisque finalement on est en
plein dans l'actualité on n'a même pas
encore passé la cmp qui a lieu la
semaine prochaine
pouvez vous m'en dire plus sur cet
accord la durée quelques explosive
disposition
et et c'est accords étaient attendus par
par ces acteurs depuis tant d'années
vraiment je vous dis je m'en réjouis
vous l'avez dit mais voilà quelques
explications et quelques précisions nous
serait très utile puisque nous sommes
vraiment dans l'actualité aujourd'hui
parlementaire de ce texte merci à vous
j'irai me l'a dit merci monsieur le
président merci messieurs je ne
reviendrai pas sur les questions des
éditeurs des gens de presse tant que
partagent les propos de mes collègues
david assouline et michel laugier je
reviendrai pas non plus sur la question
vous avez en partie répondu relatives à
la fiscalité suite aux déclarations du
g7 ceci étant dit j'aurais quand même
une question l'europe adopté vous le
savez quelles erreurs gp d une
réglementation extrêmement minces et
matière de de consentement et de
protection de la vie privée pour autant
aux deux sociétés continuent toujours de
susciter une forte méfiance je dirais
quand aux données qu'elle recueille et
surtout l'usagé qu'elles peuvent en
faire donc du coup ma question sera
extrêmement saine quelle assurance
pourrait vous donner aujourd'hui que le
traitement de ces données ne se fasse ni
au détriment du consommateur bien
évidemment mais aussi au détriment de la
société dans son ensemble je vous
remercie tous là dessus merci monsieur
le président moi j'aurais revenir sur
les faits que news et leur diffusion sur
tout puisque globalement sur le il y a
eu des outils de régulation mais c'est
surtout sur la rapidité la diffusion de
ces faits que news qu'il faut qu'il faut
réfléchir et sur cette histoire de
responsabilité de grands pouvoirs et
c'est votre grand pouvoir et tient dans
la façon dont vous avez les informations
sur vos utilisateurs ce qu'ils aiment ce
qu'ils n'aiment pas et la façon dont
vous vous organiser la formation qu'ils
reçoivent à travers des algorithmes
assez puissant de réagissent que à
l'engagement plus il ya un engagement
que la la formation est diffusé ce qui
construit des bulles de chez les
utilisateurs et qui fait là la
propagation ultra rapide d'informations
fausses et erronées qui ont la vue l'avs
cette fois ci c'est sur la santé
publique que ça ça nous met en danger
mais parfois c'est sur la démocratie et
c'est sur des attaques directes fausses
sur le dans le débat public et sa pole
le débat public il ya eu des des effets
en 2016 on l'a vu et facebook avaient
réagi avait modifié son algorithme et en
limitant parfois la porte et organique
de certaines publications etc
on a vu qu en enfermant les gens dans
des communautés comme c'était le parti
pris à partir de 2016
on a aussi créé des nouvelles bulles des
nouveaux des nouveaux groupes de deux
diffusions extrêmement rapide
d'informations complètement erronée qui
nous mettent en danger et donc il ya un
problème dans l'organisation du débat
public actuel lié à ses algorithmes liée
à la façon dont à polariser le débat
public et donc il ya peut-être besoin
d'un recours d'un ouverture démocratique
d'un contrôle démocratique de ces
algorithmes
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à ouvrir un
peu vos âneries pour savoir la façon
dont les informations sont diffusées
partager et la façon dont elles sont
affichés chez les utilisateurs ont ce
sont les informations s'organise donc ça
concerne à la fois facebook mais je
pense aussi à youtube qui a aussi son
algorithme et sa façon de diffuser du
contenu et et et qui a on l'a vu quand
c'est quand les groupes par exemple
extrémistes savent comment ils
fonctionnent permettre la diffusion de
vidéo extrêmement rapide avant même
qu'elle soit retirée de des plateformes
donc je voulais savoir si vous étiez
plutôt favorable à une ouverture
démocratique au mois d'un débat sur la
façon dont vous organiser la formation
pour vos utilisateurs merci et enfin
catherine morin desailly qui est à
distance catherine
commentant des oui très bien oui bonjour
à toutes et à tous alors je voulais
prolonger les questions de mes collègues
et poser des questions plus structurelle
peut-être qui complète ce qui a été dit
vous parler les uns comme les autres de
d'avancé de volonté de transparence
d'une responsabilité nécessaire pour
conserver la confiance c'est un mot vous
avez évoqué la confiance des
utilisateurs en évoquant en effet ce
risque de discussion et bien sûr
d'abandon des plateformes
à terme si les choses n'étaient pas
corrigés alors moi je voudrais revenir
dans la réalité des faits et vous vous
posez la question suivante quelles
garanties en réalité pouvez-vous donner
au delà de ce qui va bien sûr être
imposées en termes de régulation à
travers le disais tout le service à thé
lady et au manque est apte
sur le modèle économique inhérent à vos
plates formes parce que le modèle
économique repose très largement
aujourd'hui sur la captation et le
profilage de donner notre collègue
jeremy bas qui a évoqué la la
problématique il a mentionné le rg
mais on sait bien que healy a beau avoir
le fg la législation américaine
actuelle et notamment je fais référence
non pas au cloud hâte mais au fise à la
loi fise abl intelligence hervé hatt qui
en juin en réalité les sociétés de
fournir les données des européens sur
requête du gouvernement fédéral ou bien
de la haine et ça ça c'est une réalité
cette réalité de la législation fait que
de toute façon nos données en europe ne
sont pas qu'autant ciellement sécurisé
alors quel comportement vos société
ont-elles établi par rapport à ces
injonctions liées à la loi américaine
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
je rappelle que la cour ii
justice de l'union européenne l'été
dernier a validé l'accord de transfert
de données des européens vers les états
unis le price de cécile précisément à
cause de la loi physique on voit bien
ici la fragilité juridique sur laquelle
finalement repose aussi l'exécution de
votre modèle économique donc pouvez vous
dites nous dire pour pour nous rassurer
par ailleurs le modèle économique est
basé sur des algorithmes qui restent
opaques dans la façon dont les contenus
peuvent être aussi mise en avant et je
le pense notamment à la presse pour
l'exercice le bon exercice démocratique
que pouvez vous nous en dire également
et puis enfin ce que vous pourriez nous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé quand on
sait que thierry breton au moment où
s'élaborer le texte jugé trop savez ces
actes donc et les bretons notre
commissaire responsable de l'économie
digitale et du marché unique et la
cybersécurité a dû exiger des excuses de
google suite à un travail qui a été fait
visiblement en interne chez google pour
contrecarrer la législation qui était en
train de se penser et de se mettre en
place a été révélée par un quotidien
français
ce texte en interne ce document le ds à
ces petits tirs étaient à petit ces
documents a eu connaissance il a dû
présenter ses excuses donc quelle
confiance peut-on avoir si d'emblée
alors que s'élabore 7
cette législation européenne il ya en
interne chez google les volonté de
contrer réalisation des âmes aurions
être rassurés et de savoir quelles
dispositions depuis que ça a été mis sur
la place publique ont été mises en
oeuvre chez google pour en en effet nous
nous porter à être confiants toujours
merci de répondre à ces deux questions
je vais vous laisser répondre à ces deux
questions
et d'autres collègues qui interviendront
par la suite commence je battais si bien
merci j'ai noté plusieurs fois je
m'excuse par avance et si j'en oublie
donc n'hésitez pas à me relancer
pour ce qui concerne les gentils vax il
y a effectivement une politique de
retrait de contenus particulièrement
agressive qui fait puisque dès que vous
publiez publication qui dirait vaccinez
vous et vous aurez le cancer sur toute
chose qui n'est pas scientifiquement
fondée par agence de médecine et des
sources autorisées
je sais du conduit qui est supprimé tout
simplement
tout comme tout autre traitement qui
n'aurait pas fait la preuve de son
efficacité et qui mettrait les les gens
en danger donc on a à peu près là sur
les derniers mois 18 millions de
contenus quand même dans le monde qui
ont été retirés pour pour cette raison
et c'est un effort c'est un effort qui
continue il faut à la fois promouvoir
les mentionner des sources de contenus
crédible et c'est le travail qu'on fait
service d'information du gouvernement et
aussi retirer les contenus nocifs pour
la population effectivement il ya
parfois des débats sur des contenus
grille parce que des gens peuvent
questionner l'efficacité d'un vaccin ou
s'interroger sur la nécessité de se
faire vacciner
bon voilà on n'est pas tout à fait là
dans le pur anti vaccinaux se dire et ça
peut parfois nécessiter une analyse un
peu plus fine sur le cyber harcèlement
madame la sénatrice cet après midi je
crois qu'il ya une réunion est quelqu'un
d'autre qui sera présent pour vous
apporter beaucoup plus de détails que je
vais en faire mais c'est un point tout à
fait légitime j'ai envie de dire les
adultes ne lis pas les cgu les jeunes
encore moins voilà donc comment on
arrive à a à faire pour que les cgu les
conditions d'utilisation soit apparente
comprise et rappelé c'est un vrai défi
donc on a travaillé sur deux choses sur
des rats des centres d'information
adaptés à la fois aux jeunes on pourra
vous en faire démonstration et aux
parents parce que c'est quand même très
importants ils ont un rôle dans bien sûr
dans tout ça et si en tout cas le
travail confié qu'elle s'en vont
d'association comme i enfance ou de
génération numérique sur sur ces sujets
pour ce qui est des jeunes de moins
qui s'inscrivent je le rappelais
puissions m'écoute ce sera l'occasion on
ne peut pas s'inscrire avant 13 ans
voilà donc si on trouve un compte avant
13 ans on le supprime
c'est rédhibitoire on ne demande pas la
carte d'identité un jeune de 13 ans et
demi pour savoir s'il peut s'inscrire sa
soul est vrai beaucoup de questions
éthiques et légales
on ne pourra pas le temps de débattre
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas on ne peut
pas s'inscrire avant 13 ans donc je le
rappelle si les parents qui m'écoutent
et des leurs enfants c'est vraiment
important qu'il le comprenne
pour leur chiper des dons qu'il en
vigueur depuis un certain nombre
d'années maintenant on va dire on a un
petit peu de recul
ce qu'on remarque en tout cas de notre
point de vue c'est que le régulateur ou
les régulateurs européens ne nous
laissent en rien tranquille sur le sujet
ils ont bien raison
ça a été mentionné aussi vu la masse de
données que l'on traite
il est tout à fait normal qu'on soit en
conformité donc ça veut dire question de
consentement ça veut dire mettre en
place en interne tout un tas de
processus de leur pardon pour le
l'anglicisme ne croyez pas traduction
l'accountability sera avoir un data
protection officer documenté tout ce
qu'on fait faire du privacy by design
d'ailleurs c'est aussi l'objet on a eu
suite à la sphère cambridge a signé des
accords avec de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
le régulateur américain qui nous oblige
à être extraordinairement transparent
sur le fabrication de nouveaux produits
donc je dire des deux côtés de
l'atlantique aujourd'hui de toute façon
il ya eu une montée en puissance de la
régulation des données et c'est très
bien comme ça et on peut aussi remarquer
que quand on ne respecte pas leurs gpd
on risque 4 % d'un manque de son chiffre
d'affaires donc de toute façon une
entreprise qui respecte pas le g plus
large plaie il n'y a aucun intérêt pour
des raisons de confiance que je viens de
mentionner puisque les gens s'en irait
et par ailleurs pour les enquêtes et des
sanctions extraordinairement désagréable
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui voilà ne suscite aucun débat
il faut appliquer leur gp d après on est
dans des domaines techniques parfois
assez subtil donc il faut avoir des
négociations des discussions avec les
régulateurs mais à ces gens c'est la vie
d'une entreprise régulé qui parle à son
régulateur comme j'imagine opérateurs de
télécoms avec l'arcep etc
j'attire quand même votre votre
attention sur un point qui sans aucune
malice c'est que dans la loi sur le
piratage qui va faire l'objet de votre
cmp bientôt il y a une
position qui concerne la capacité pour
le pérenne c'est à dire ce groupe
d'experts du gouvernement de d'effectuer
pour des raisons qu'on peut discuter
bien sûr d'effectuer une collecte de
données à des fins d'études auprès des
états de forme ce qu'on appelle pendant
en anglais du data scrapping quelque
part je remarque ce suscité aucun débat
aucun avis de la cnil que ça passe un
petit peu comme ça quelque part
alors si c'est si c'est fondé et que
c'est nécessaire parlons-en ayons un
débat demandant la cnil ce qu'elle en
pense mais voyez la question des données
elle dépasse de loin la seule question
de nos plateformes et et c'est pas un
petit sujet à quelque part et ça
nécessite je pense j'en appelle quand
j'ai tout à l'heure la sensibilité du
sénat sur ces sujets à avoir à poser ces
questions et à essayer de voir si ces
dispositions comme l avait été fait en
matière fiscale il ya je crois deux ans
et légitime proportionnée organisée etc
etc c'est le question du moins delà de
la méthode et je veux pas être trop long
mais je vais continuer sur les données
la question de du transfert aux états
unis
et côté de toute façon interne est ce
qu'il est la mondialisation est ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui il ya des
transferts de biens de services des deux
côtés de l'atlantique et qui implique
des transferts de données
donc ça concerne pas que facebook et
d'autres entreprises j'ai parfois
entendu vous êtes plus fort ou moi vous
êtes au niveau des états j'ai envie de
dire dans cette affaire
la preuve est faite que non la preuve
est faite que non parce que nous devons
respecter parfois des règles de
souveraineté puisqu'on est là dans
l'exercice de la souveraineté des deux
côtés de l'atlantique et donc nous ce
qu'on souhaite c'est quand même que ces
transferts puisse continuer comme il
existait dans le passé avec des
garanties supplémentaires parce que de
toute façon on irait vers une disruption
de biens et de services du des deux
côtés de l'atlantique qui ne concerne
pas que le secteur du numérique et donc
oui ce n'est pas normal si la haine et
ça a trop de pouvoir que d'autres
agences de renseignement par ailleurs du
côté européen
soyons pas hypocrites
dispose de pouvoirs d'investigation etc
etc
mais j'ai envie de dire je vais presque
envie de demander aux états de régler
ces questions comme en matière fiscale
parce qu'au final c'est aux états de
faire des accords internationaux
si osé cas aux états de faire les lois
qui concerne le renseignement est donc
nous nous sommes on ne peut que dire
en europe il faut le faire et on peut
aller dire à washington de le faire
aussi de faire les efforts qu'il faut
pour que les européens soient contents
et permet de cet accord comment il a pu
faire matière fiscale mais au final il
est important que les états dans leur
pleine capacité se saisisse de ces
sujets dont on peut en reparler mais je
ne crois pas qu'on soit en désaccord sur
ces sujets et simplement du point de vue
d'une entreprise
on est dans une position particulière
qui est de devoir appliquer appliquer
les lois et de les challengers pardon
pour l'anglais devant les tribunaux
quand c'est nécessaire je crois que
microsoft l'avait fait et d'autres
entreprises étaient venus en soutien de
microsoft
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai couvert l'essentiel
des sujets et je voulais pas prendre
trop de temps de parole
vis-à-vis de google pour les faits que
news pour les élections écouter on a des
dispositifs de partenariat de fact
checking qui existent notamment avec la
sp quand une une information a fait
l'objet d'un fact checking sa viralité
s'effondre de 90% que la page qui a émis
ce genre de faits que nous est aussi
sanctionné si une page serbe et c'est de
gagner de l'argent avec ça elle sera
aussi sanctionné pourra pas faire de
publicité ou renvoyés vers des choses
qui lui permet de gagner de l'argent et
par ailleurs l'enjeu c'est aussi de
pousser quelque part dans l'algorithme
si on peut dire les contenus de qualité
donc il n'ya pas de retrait de toutes
les filles que nous mais en tout cas le
dispositif de fact checking qui est
apparue dès 2017 en france aujourd'hui
il fonctionne bien des études tendent à
montrer que la viralité de ces faits que
news est en baisse donc il faut
continuer l'effort
on aura aussi une vigilance particulière
pour les élections pour ce qui concerne
les interférences étrangères
je ne cite aucun pays mais voilà donc on
travaille déjà on a des échanges avec
notamment massador
verdier qui pilote ces sujets avec
d'autres institutions gouvernementales
et donc on et voilà sur plusieurs
plusieurs fronts en même temps mais
rassurez-vous évidemment il s'agit pas
de jeu vous dire nous on influence
aucune élection moi derrière mon bureau
j'ai une influence aucune élection
le problème c'est la capacité alors
c'est la capacité d'autres à utiliser
l'outil pour influencer l'élection est
notre responsabilité à ce moment là
c'est de veiller à ce que ces gens ne le
fasse pas voilà mais il faut être juste
je pense qu une précision qui a son
importance facebook en tant que tel
alors son petit bureau ne fait pas de l'
influence directe d'élections celle
usage de l'outil par d'autres mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut se défausser
sur d'autres
ça veut dire que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut adresser le problème pour le
résoudre je remercie la parole à un
google sur la question du contrôle
démocratique des halles briques posées
par thomas dessus vous n'avez pas
répondu monsieur m'a téléphoné
aujourd'hui alors évidente
alors je crois que c'est l'objet des
discussions au sein du dsa il va de soi
que transparence va aujourd'hui avec
régulation donc c'était déjà au coeur du
la mission de monsieur loutrel qui
concernait la régulation des réseaux
sociaux il ya de cela deux ans la
mission dit rice book
il conclut son rapport par cette
transparence et on peut soutenir cette
jeune arche à prévoir comment elles se
basent il ya un régulateur viadeo liste
indépendante voilà c'est quelque chose
qui se fait dans beaucoup de secteurs de
l'économie on pense aux secteurs
bancaire et réseau dit et voilà donc il
ya beaucoup de choses qui vont
fatalement se mettre en place et qui
sont aujourd'hui nécessaires et qu'on ne
peut on ne doit pas refuser
donc la question est toujours sur le
comment mais sur le principe il n'y a
pas de difficulté principe messieurs mis
d'accord au goût elle merci beaucoup
madame la sénatrice si vous évoquez le
partenariat en effet avec le l'adea gp
et et la sef c'est à partir maria qui va
courir sur les dix prochaines années qui
couve deux dimensions une licence pour
l'utilisation en france des oeuvres est
un fonds pour les artistes membres
devant eu l'occasion de rencontrer la
directrice générale la semaine dernière
je n'ai rencontré et c'est le tout début
du programme
nous sommes particulièrement excités de
notre côté par les autres
unité devant nous pour travailler avec
ces artistes et avec ses différents
fonds et je serais heureux quand nous
aurons plus de détails dans les années
qui viennent de venir régulièrement vous
faire un point sur ce sujet là c'est le
tout début
la deuxième question qui avait été posé
sur le modèle économique de google en
effet quelques fois derrière le mot
gafas se cachent quelques subtilités sur
des modèles économiques un peu différent
la grande majorité aujourd'hui des
revenus de google s'est fait par le
moteur de recherche et la façon dans la
publicité apparaît sur le moteur de
recherche et pas sur un détail sur des
individus mais aussi sur une requête
spécifique
si on cherche le mot restaurant grec à
montpellier c'est la possibilité pour
les restaurants grecs à montpellier qui
souhaitent être visible sur le moteur de
recherche de faire une recherche sur ce
mot clé spécifique
donc on arrive à avoir cette précision
là on ce qui amène avec question d'après
qui avait été posé sur la question des
données
j'ai la conviction c'est à des sujets
les plus importants
il ya un appétit une ambition pour
chacun de nous comme citoyen d'avoir ce
contrôle sur ces données sur n'importe
quel utilisateur de google vous avez la
possibilité en allant sur la page mon
compte de définir quelles données vont
être gardés qu'est-ce que vous souhaiter
qu'il soit partagé comment ça va être
utilisé avec ce contrôle pour les
utilisateurs si vous allez sur google
maps par exemple on voit qu'un certain
nombre d'utilisateurs aime garder tout
l'historique c'est formidable vous
pouvez voir depuis dix ans vous avez été
en vacances laquelle restaurant et tout
le détail et d'autres souhaitent que
cette information soit effacée
immédiatement donc c'est vraiment cette
notion de contrôle qui est importante et
qui est clé et on voit aujourd'hui en a
chaque jour plus de 20 millions de
personnes qui vont sur ses pages et qui
choisissent de changer ces différents
critères pour avoir le contrôle
spécifique sur les données telles
qu'elles sont utilisées et avant de
laisser la parole à benoît tabaka
peut-être de deux autres éléments qui
qui sont revenus la question suivante
était sur la question de cloud sur
lequel là aussi nous avons entendu les
inquiétudes qui ont été évoqués nous
avons mis en place et nous l'avons
annoncé quelques mois en partenariat
avec ovh qui permet aux
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de cet accord
à faire en sorte que toutes les données
qui vont être stockés vont être stockés
en france par ovh et apporter les
garanties de sécurité qui ont été
évoqués tout à l'heure donc je pense que
ça c'est lui le point le plus important
sur la partie de cloud est la dernière
question madame la sénatrice des
saillies sur le sujet de de rétablir la
confiance on on a parlé tout à l'heure
des citations de spider man nous avons
aussi citer la citation de martin luther
king qui répétait nous devons à vivre
apprendre à vivre comme des frais ou
nous mourrons comme des imbéciles et
nous avons sur ce sujet là la vocation à
continuer à vraiment nous inscrire
continue à écouter à être engagée avec
vous pour trouver ces solutions
nous y sommes engagés et je vais ajouter
rapidement contenu je pense tout aussi
du temps plusieurs éléments au finir sur
la question des données
un des aspects aussi pour répondre à des
questions de madame la sénatrice mme
morin dessailly sur le futur aussi et
l'évolution des modèles et ça c'est
intéressant là avoir en tête c'est que
le modèle en fait qu'on connaît de la
publicité en train de profondément
évolué et va évoluer dans les prochains
mois et prochaines années beaucoup d'eux
d'entre vous entendu parler pendant les
20 dernières années du principe du
cookie ce feu ce petit fichier qui
s'installe sur votre ordinateur et qui
permet aux différents acteurs de la
publicité de pouvoir récupérer un
certain nombre d'informations afin de
mieux personnaliser la publicité ses
coûts qui vont progressivement
disparaître côté google nous on a
annoncé que dans les prochains mois dans
les faits on arrêtera de soutenir
supporter le tracking publicitaire sur
la base de coûts qui de ne plus faire du
tracking individuelle mais bien
évidemment de remonter dans un autre
logique
c'est à dire que la publicité
personnalisée existera toujours
parce que elle apporte une valeur
notamment à la fois côté éditeurs parce
que ça permet d'en de générer pour les
éditeurs notamment de presse mais
différents sites internet des revenus
additionnels mais aussi côté utilisateur
parce que ça permet d'éviter d'être trop
harceler toujours par la même publicité
mais une faute
vu que ce suivi se fasse sur l'individu
et la personne et donc on est en train
de réfléchir d'imaginer avec aussi
puisque ça concerne finalement le monde
entier et l'ensemble des acteurs de la
publicité
les solutions qu'on peut mettre en place
là dessus mais soyez sûr que d'ici les
12 24 prochains mois
ce mécanisme la disparaîtra
progressivement d'internet et de manière
générale sur sur la question 2 je vais
revenir aussi sur votre question madame
morano saillie sur sur le fameux
document que vous évoquiez c'est
important parce que c'est vrai que on le
document en fait c'est quelque chose qui
doit dater je pense de septembre octobre
avant la publication par la commission
européenne de ses projets de
réglementation sur la régulation du
numérique on appelle des salles d emma
pour utiliser des acronymes des plus
courants on ne savait pas comment ces
régulations en fait allé se présenter
et surtout on avait vu apparaître
énormément de propositions d'idées mises
sur la table par toutes les parties
prenantes
poussan pour que ces régulations vise
spécifiquement un petit nombre d'acteurs
et nommément nous est de dire il ne faut
pas une régulation pour le numérique
il ne faut pas une régulation pour
renforcer à la lutte contre les contenus
haineux il ne faut pas une régulation
pour l'innovation il faut une régulation
contre contre un certain nombre
d'acteurs pas un certain nombre de
pratiques mais véritablement disant nous
nominativement quand le texte a été
publié est effectivement sous
d'artichaut il a expliqué aux
commissaires aucun tir et bretons on a
été rassuré que ce n'était pas là
proches lui par la commission européenne
et que son approche était d'avoir des
règles destinées à renforcer la lutte
contre le contenu problématique d'avoir
des nouvelles règles en matière
d'activités de manière d'opérer sur le
titre et européens et qui s'appliquait
de manière transversale à différentes
entreprises
il ya des effets de seuil mais qui
s'appliquait de manière transversale à
des entreprises peu importe l'origine de
l'entreprise sa nationalité ou son nom
et donc c'est en cela pour vous dire
qu'est ce qui a changé depuis ce qui a
changé surtout
c'est que on est fortement engagée
notamment avec les régulateurs français
qui travaillent sur la préparation ces
deux textes là avec des réunions très
régulière avec le partage de nos
réflexions
le partage de nos propositions et des
échanges collatéraux avec eux sur
comment avancer et pour venir sur sur la
question aussi de l'opacité la
supervision des algorithmes qui est un
point aussi important
aujourd'hui il ya un acteur qu'on nous
dit hélas mais qui a un rôle important
c'est le csa et notamment sur la base
des des pouvoirs qui lui ont été
confiées par la loi sur la lutte contre
la désinformation on remet chaque année
un rapport annuel au csa on a des
réunions régulières avec son comité sa
commission et ses membres et j'ai une
pensée particulière pour michel léridon
qui était celle qui au sein du csa et
porter le sujet et avec qui on engageait
quasiment tous les mois sur ce sujet là
et effectivement on a déjà un travail
qui est fait et si le sujet vous
intéresse notamment il y avait un
rapport qui a été rendu par le csa sur
les algorithmes par exemple de
recommandations sur youtube qui fait
écho à la question fait que nous et
entonnant parler le père n c'est aussi
un des acteurs qui vient en plus dans
cet univers là on a aussi des des
échanges avec eux et on est engagé avec
donc je vais pas rajouté peut-être de
clément sur les tchèques nous rapidement
pour pas dire qu'on élude la question
mais parce que on a des approches assez
similaire l'approchent fake news et de
lutte contre l'effet news côté google et
youtube est très clair c'est que ces
contenus n'ont pas vocation à être
présents sur la plateforme
on a trois actions qui sont assez
simples la première c'est de retirer les
contenus qu'ils sont illégaux et ça
c'est le premier point parce que c'est
un point qu'on aime quand même rappeler
c'est que les contenus illégaux n'ont
pas vocation à être sur notre plate
forme et qu'on les déteste qu'on est au
courant on les supprime
deuxième élément les contenus qui ne
s'en être illégaux pose problème peuvent
être retirés aussi parce qu'on a des
règles claires et donc ça c'est le
premier en action on va retirer le
deuxième action c'est que certains
contenus vont être gris soit on dit un
peu à la frontière on ne sait pas
comment les traités ne sont pas illégaux
on peut pas avoir une action forte
dessus et donc pour cela on va en fait
les faire disparaître
on va en fait tout simplement les
en quelque sorte réduire la visibilité
et la viralité de ses contenus là et les
rendre moins visible est bien évidemment
le dernier point c'est que en échange
qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait remonter un
certain nombre de contenus que nous on
appelle faisant autorité
par exemple si vous chercher aujourd'hui
des informations sur le co vide les
premiers résultats dans youtube ça sera
des vidéos de france 24
ça sera des vidéos du monde ça sera des
informations du gouvernement parce qu'on
pense que sur un grand nombre de sujets
et pas uniquement les questions de
factures sur un grand nombre de sujets
il faut d'abord privilégier les sources
faisant autorité dernier les
intervenants je vais demander d'être
rapide dans le question qui rentrait de
lévis oui monsieur président moi je sais
effectivement vous avez déjà répondu
monsieur bâtisse est concerné les des
contenus haineux en fait je voulais
quand même vous parler peut-être d'une
d'une affaire qui a cessé d'être c'était
la ferme il a deux jeunes mineurs qui a
subi sur les réseaux sociaux donc sur
facebook et sur twitter
une déferlement de messages et haineux
je crois que c'était plus de deux cent
vingt minutes
donc ce sont plus de centaines de
milliers de messages d'insultés de
menaces de mort qui ont été diffusées
sur son nom à son encontre devant de
tels phénomènes les autorités sont
souvent désemparés ne peuvent pas agir
efficacement sans la coopération pleine
et entière des plateformes numériques
alors vous avez répondu mais j'ai pas
été très satisfait je vous avoue de la
réponse est ce que vous considérez que
le nécessaire est fait afin de lutter
contre ces phénomènes ont parlé tout à
l'heure de l'âge limite pour ouvrir un
compte sur facebook
effectivement il suffit de dire qu'on a
13 ans howard 14 ans alors qu'on en a
cinq ou six et on ouvre un compte sur
facebook c'est très compliqué de
dénoncer des lancers parce que c'est bon
ce n'est pas forcément faux pas
forcément visibles mais beaucoup de deux
parents nous ont alertés sur la facilité
d'ouvrir un compte sur facebook donc
peut-être que demander une pièce
d'identité ou demander l'accord des
parents pour les mineurs de 13 ans pour
être pour être une solution et d'une
question quel plan d'action est
envisagée au sein de facebook france
pour développer davantage la modération
de ces contenus est nu et ne ne plus
voir d'autres affaires milla je vous
remercie
j'aurais monde connaît merci président
merci messieurs de vous soumettre à ce
cet exercice qui n'est pas simple merci
pour la franchise de vos réponses
on vit un moment comme souvent dans
cette commission une audition
extrêmement intéressante un peu étrange
aujourd'hui
avant toute chose je voudrais dire aussi
que ici vous l'avez vu depuis le début
de l'audition nous sommes tous des
consommateurs effrénés donc nous sommes
si j'employais un vocable à la mode
d'aujourd'hui nous sommes contaminés et
si jamais vos services s'arrêter en une
fraction de seconde
nos égos souffrirait beaucoup parce que
tout est fiévreuse mans ce que l'on fait
donc faut bien avoir conscience de ça et
j'en ai parfaitement conscience étant
moi-même addict de toutes ces solutions
vos sociétés ont débarqué en europe
elles ont même recruté en europe
et là c'est un choc culturel est en fait
c'est de ça dont on parle donc excusez
ma question président si elle est
peut-être plus générale mais elle est à
mon sens fondamental parce que c'est là
qu'est le problème alors ensuite bien
sûr l'architecturé technique très
intéressante mais l'essentiel est
ailleurs et ce choc culturel s'exprimer
en tout cas il se concrétise sous deux
formes pour le meilleur et pour le pire
le meilleur c'est le droit d'auteur est
forcément devant voir ces entreprises
américaines se fracasser sur le droit
d'auteur
alors qu'elle le combattent assidûment
violemment depuis des années à quelque
chose de très intéressant pour
l'observateur que je suis et le
pratiquant également pour le pire c est
ce que nous dressons tous les jours tous
les jours d'ailleurs des petites
barricades qui s'appelle la rgpp des la
cnil ou d'autres qui sont maintenant
tellement ubuesque qu'elle nous met nous
mêmes dans notre fonctionnement normal
hormis vos sociétés dans un un délire
kafkaïen quotidien que nous sommes
nombreux d'ailleurs tous à stigmatiser
mais celle
réalité alors pour faire très vite
puisque on me le demande alors que ça
demanderait beaucoup plus de temps mais
peut-être pas avec vous mais je veux
reprendre ce qui concrétise ce que je
dis on ne parle
rupert murdoch et moi je vous parle de
marché donc ma question aujourd'hui
c'est comment pouvez vous concrètement
indépendamment david assouline l'a
souligné tout à l'heure on sent qu'il ya
dans la dans la mécanique est un cran
qui est passé à vous avez vous ici vos
patrons je sais pas et je suis certain
du contraire même mais vous vous lavez
parfaitement compris pourquoi parce que
vous êtes la cheville ouvrière et que
vous avez compris pour travailler ici
puisque vous êtes issus de ces cultures
il ya absolument besoin de le réserver
ma question c'est comment pensez vous
concrètement indiqué que vous vous
adapter à notre culture européenne et
française en particulier puisque nous
sommes les fers de lance de cela et
c'est pas pour rien qu'on ait le peuple
des lumières même si ça fait un moment
que l'éclairage est un petit peu
affaibli mais comment souhaitez-vous le
monde le montrer concrètement
indépendamment des discussions que nous
avons mais qui chez vous ça ceci souvent
aux mots vous avez employé négociations
juridiques c'est le cas pour le père
teneur doc et c'est la façon de faire
c'est dans les usages pour nous le droit
d'auteur c'est au delà de la négociation
et du juridique
ça fait partie de nos gènes catherine
morin desailly la parole catherine oui
merci monsieur le président je voulais
rebondir sur deux réponses qui ont été
faites par d'abord monsieur battisti
représentants de de facebook que je
crois très volontiers quand il répond à
madame vous laisse péronier que derrière
son écran il ne cherche aucunement à
manipuler les opinions politiques dans
la perspective d'influencer les scrutins
électoraux de la même manière je pense
que la majorité des employés de facebook
ne sont pas en effet dans cet état
d'esprit
néanmoins je voudrais quand même
souligner que
mark zuckerber d'ailleurs auditionné par
le congrès américain puis auditionné par
le parlement européen n'a pas dit la
vérité est que ce qu'a démontré
l'homologue de monsieur lafon à la
chambre des communes d'amicalistes dans
un rapport qui a été partagée d'ailleurs
par de nombreux parlementaires à
l'international sur la fère cambridge
analytique à voir l' affaire c'est que
le boat de facebook était très en
connaissance qu'il y avait eu l'
infiltration des russes et qu'il y avait
une fragilisation en fait des réseaux à
l'occasion de la campagne pour les
élections américaines en corrélation
avec cambridge analytique a donc tout ça
a été démontrée donc le bond était très
au courant mais n'ont rien fait d'où
l'absence de confiance que l'on peut
aujourd'hui avoir par rapport à ces
pratiques donc ses engagements beaucoup
plus fort que nous aimerions bien sûr à
voir
je voudrais quand même le préciser est
précise et aussi ce sera peut-être
question à laquelle vous pourriez
répondre c'est que à l'époque ce sont
les données de 83 millions de de comment
dirais-je pas seulement de facebook
heures parce qu'il avait été démontré
qu'ils avaient eu des shadows profile
autrement dit des amis de facebook qui
ne sont pas sur facebook mais dont on
peut construire des profils à travers un
recoupement de données avait été aussi
concerné alors aujourd'hui quid de ces
châteaux crocs face j'aimerais bien
avoir une réponse là dessus et puis j'ai
aussi une question complémentaire à
poser soit monsieur mrsa monsieur tabac
car je ne sais plus lequel d'entre vous
a répondu à la question du stockage des
données pour nous rassurer par rapport à
l'application du rgp des et la
sécurisation des données des européens
en établissant le fait que ces données
grâce au partenariat avec ovh seraient
stockées en en europe c'est déjà un
élément certes de satisfaction mais nous
savons bien que c'est pas tellement le
stockage des données qui compte mais
leur traitement par des jolies chaîne
pour le coup appartenant aux sociétés
que vous société que vous
représenter or c'est toujours soumis à
la législation pour lequel je vous ai
posé une question à laquelle elle avait
pour lui ni l'un ni l'autre c'est à dire
l'application de la loi
suisa aujourd'hui en l'état vous êtes en
europe représentant de la société
auxquels bien sûr vous devez une loyauté
dans le dans le travail mais malgré tous
en tant qu'européens comment vivez-vous
cette situation qui fait que encore une
fois la loi américaine pas la loi vise à
en juin ouvrant la possibilité sur
requête du gouvernement fédéral et donc
du coût des services secrets comme la
msa que les données des européens
traités par vos sociétés doivent être
fournis si elles sont demandées
donc comment ça s'organise chez vous
c'est ce que j'aimerais savoir par
rapport aux directions concernées qui
peuvent se voir contactée directement
sans forcément d'ailleurs passé pas
voilà les chefs et chefs de vos
entreprises
voilà je vais vous répondre j'ai
vraiment à cette question elle est
essentielle et le docker du débat
aujourd'hui avec la validation du projet
ces chiffres à la dernière intervention
de sonia de la provôté oui où les sons
répondra dernière c'est très court parce
que beaucoup de choses ont été dites sur
sur les données mais je pense que c'est
vraiment le coeur du sujet c'est comment
on est protégé par rapport à l'usagé de
la géolocalisation naturel réseaux
familiaux nos goûts nos appétence
politique par exemple nos questions
sanitaires des données de santé
on voit bien que tout ça finalement fait
l'objet d'amalgamés les algorithmes ont
pour missions de en tout cas on imagine
de nous amener dans cette fameuse bulle
qui est évoqué tout à l'heure et un
environnement qui nous met dans ce qu'on
aime et un peu moins dense qu'on n'aime
pas quoi et donc finalement ont créé des
groupes dans la société
ces relais par par des domaines bien
bien précis moi je voulais juste poser
une question par rapport à ça c'est
parce que du coup je m'interroge sur la
façon dont vous cherchez à avoir les les
algorithmes pas vous personnellement
société dont on cherche à avoir les
données pour qui est ce qui motive cette
recherche de données quel usage en est
en effet derrière comme on est protégé
et est ce que cet usage personne de
données personnelles au bout du compte
nous amène à une exploitation personnel
dans des entreprises dont le but est pas
forcément altruiste et je parle des
données de santé parce que je pense que
c'est absolument la caricature de tout
ça il ya vu un questionnaire sur
facebook co vide
on a eu ça pendant pendant plusieurs
mois et donc j'ai moi je les bats je
n'ai pas répondu bien sûr mais j'imagine
qu'un très grand nombre
c'était répondait parce qu'on a besoin
de connaître au plan international
national d'exposition et d'épidémies je
voulais poser juste une question qui a
été acquis à commander le questionnaire
pourquoi ce questionnaire a été a été
mis en oeuvre
que sont devenus les données de ce
questionnaire qui en a fait
l'exploitation est ce que finalement
facebook de son propre fait s'est pas
lancé dans une participation au
altruiste
j'allais dire et bienveillante vis-à-vis
de la population mondiale puisse
habitent cette épidémie en quelque sorte
voilà pourquoi ce questionnaire et
qu'est ce que c'est devenu tout ça vous
laissons répondre pas qui commence
battisti je jeu très sincèrement je sais
que l'on publie parfois des
questionnaires pour savoir si vous avez
trouvé telle ou telle information utile
sais pas si cela dont on parle c'est pas
moi même mais ça parlait de quelle
question c'est juste pour ça ne s'est
pas d'accord lorsque je vous propose pas
ce que je veux pas répondre à côté de la
plaque ça me chagrinerait peut-être
qu'on peut sans parler a posteriori mes
impôts répondent sur la question des
données sentent écoutés on traite aucune
donnée de santé ont fait de
l'information sur la santé je pense que
c'est ce qui est attendu de nous en ce
moment parce que ne peut pas nous
demander tout et son contraire
donc on doit lutter contre l'effet que
nous mais je pense qu'on n'est pas dans
le domaine de la santé
je pense que dr l'iba beaucoup beaucoup
plus de données de santé que facebook
sincèrement donc
rassure mais voilà c'est pour vous dire
je pense que si on met les choses en
perspective aujourd'hui c'est c'est
moins notre affaire on a d'autres sujets
qui ont été évoqués ici et c'est
vraiment pas notre affaire
du coup j'en mourrai sur les autres
réponses oui voilà donc sur rapidement
sur sur mila pour être très clair depuis
le jour 1 où cette crise est arrivée
nous sommes en relation et notamment
grâce au partenariat qu'on a eue avec
qui en france sur un système d'alerté
d'urgence avec elle les contenus mais
vous imaginez bien le défi ont été
retirés c'est quelque chose qui continue
sur lequel on est extraordinairement
vigilant chez moi même relation que son
avocat voilà qui peut m'appeler quand il
veut pour me signaler tel ou tel
problème et c'est vous l'avez dit
symptomatique de quelque chose qui est
malheureusement enracinée dans la
société
les réseaux le lire le harcèlement
existait avant les réseaux sociaux sans
raconter ma vie j'ai moi même été
victime de quolibets à l'école parce que
je travaillais trop bien en classe mais
je dois dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
réseaux sociaux qui faisait que que ce
problème continue à la maison donc
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui est attendu de
nous c'est d'avoir des règles d'avoir
des outils et des modérateurs pour
retirer ces contenus c'est ce que nous
faisons est d'avoir des partenariats
pour que ça pour que pour qu'on ait des
gens qui nous aident aussi à le faire
mais ce que je voudrais aussi dire c'est
que ce convoi et que le rôle des parents
de l'éducation nationale belge de l'asse
devenir point de société exactement
comme les la sécurité routière c'est à
dire que il ya dix ans on avait à peu
près je crois dix mille morts par an sur
les routes et tout le monde disait on ne
peut rien faire c'est comme ça les gens
sont comme ça c'est comme ça bon jacques
chirac en a fait une grande cause
nationale et l'a dit maintenant tout le
monde ce moteur de la table chacun va
participer à régler ce problème et c'est
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui on a
quatre mille morts par an c'est encore
trop mais on a quand même diminué de
moitié
donc ya pas de fatalité le problème
c'est qu'il faut assumer que chacun a sa
part de responsabilité que ça va prendre
du temps parce que malheureusement c'est
devenu un phénomène de société en fait
dire qu'il dépasse la seule question de
l' usage d'un outil de réseau social
mais il faut lutter contre ça donc il
faut le nom collaborent avec la justice
pour que justice passe et c'est ce qui
est en train d'arriver
il faut qu'on mette les outils faucon
mettre les moyens que ça donc je veux
pas être malheureusement là on est un
cours sur le temps mais il faut pas
douter de notre volonté mais ça va
prendre un certain temps sur la
modération pour vous donner un chiffre
on a à peu près trente cinq mille
personnes qui travaillent sur ces sujets
et au dernier trimestre on a retiré pour
donner des chiffres mais c'est il faut
entrer dans les détails
plusieurs millions de contenus qui ont à
voir avec les discours de haine soit
avec le harcèlement mais en tout cas il
faut il faut continuer sur la question
des données et je ne vois pas la laisser
de côté et du droit d'auteur
écoutez bien sûr moi en tant
qu'européens j'ai ma sensibilité j'étais
à la fac de droit ici voilà donc bien
sûr que je suis sensible à ces questions
et du coup on participe aussi à ce que
des entreprises internationales évolué
et comprennent mieux certains sujets
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur la
régulation des contenus je peux vous
dire que voilà des choses ont été faites
ont progressé donc sincèrement mais je
reviendrai quand même un bon point qui
de dire au final ce sont les états qui
font les lois sur le renseignement c'est
pas nous voilà et donc il faut régler
ces questions du point de vue des états
on peut contribuer à ce débat
mais c'est l'état qui légifèrent donc il
va falloir il travaillé ensemble sur la
question enfin des groupes et des
filtres
c'est quelque chose aussi qui est
souvent mentionné la un réseau social
vous généralement vous demander comme
amis les gens qui sont déjà mis avec
vous et donc dominique cardon explique
très bien que vous apportez déjà quelque
part sur réseau social votre vie sociale
vos amis si la plupart sont de gauche et
bien vous allez rendu compte d'une
gauche et s'ils sont de droite vous
aurez du contenu de droit et ensuite
vous allez être attiré par un certain
nombre d'activités qui vous concerne
vous êtes chasseur vous êtes fait des
maquettes vous vous êtes engagés dans
telle ou telle cause vous allez dans des
groupes qui vous concerne donc oui c'est
une expérience intrasèquement personnel
est ce qu'elle vous enferme dans ce jeu
je pense qu'il faut modérer ses propos
quand vous regardez ses news matin midi
et soir
vous êtes orienté dans une certaine
bulle si vous regardez bfm tv vous êtes
orienté dans une certaines choses donc
je pense qu'il faut relativiser ces
problèmes et surtout je pense qui est
important c'est d'ouvrir nos jeux
terminera là dessus nous donner à la
recherche parce que je suis d'accord
avec un point qui est de dire en finale
on sait pas trop parce que vous nous
dites tout ça mais on sait pas trop ce
qui se passe donc il ya de plus en plus
d'initiatives qui visent à offrir à la
recherche notre même française en jeu
possible d'ouvrir les api pour voir
on parle des algorithmes et de viralité
de quoi on parle ça touche qui et
comment
et donc ça c'est un travail qu'il faut
faire en plus je dirais de la régulation
stricto sensu des éléments pour ce qui
est du droit d'auteur écouter ses il n'y
a pas plus à dire qu'il faut respecter
le droit d'auteur
voilà il y à cesser le droit il doit
s'appliquer
il ya des outils pour sa 60e outils
technologiques soit ce sont des outils
financiers
aujourd'hui il n'a pas mégoté sur le
respect du droit d'auteur c'est un droit
fondamental il doit être respectée donc
soyez rassuré sur sa forme je voulais
être
et peut-être juste une question à part
peut-être juste rajouter sur l'élément
des concernant les ingérences peut alors
déjà concernant l' influence de la
sphère cambridge indique à sur le brésil
il ya eu une enquête qui a été révélé
donc en octobre 2020 par l'information
commissioner's office qui est donc une
autorité indépendante du gouvernement
britannique qui rapporte au parlement
britannique et qui démontre clairement
que la sphère cambridge et indiqua n'a
eu aucune influence sur le vote du
breakbeat
donc en termes d'impact sur les
élections déjà ses limites et concernant
l'ingérence et les tentatives
d'ingérence pour ajouter sur ce qui a
été fait est ce que nous mettons en
place en amont des élections
donc nous travaillons avec l'ambassadeur
du numérique monsieur bergé sur ces
questions mais nous avons chez facebook
des équipes qui sont dédiés aux enquêtes
là dessus et qui chaque mois produisent
des rapports sur ce que nous constatons
sur notre plateforme et notamment ce que
nous appelons les comportements
inauthentique coordonnées qui sont en
fait des tentatives de réseau de
création de faux comptes etc pour
influencer le débat public et donc il ya
des équipes d' enquête qui révèle très
précisément ce qui se passe quand nous
identifions de tels réseaux nous les
fermons y en a plus de sens qui ont été
fermé le puits 2017 et en matière de
faux comptes parce que ces réseaux sont
souvent alimentés par des faux comptes
sont un milliard cinq de faux comptes
que nous avons supprimé ce premier
second trimestre par exemple pour lutter
contre ce phénomène
donc il ya des mesures qui sont prises
utilisent vraiment à garantir et à
limiter autant que possible en
collaboration avec les autorités
l'influencé des puissances étrangères
sur des élections justes un point de
précisions vous avez 10 35 modérateur
j'imagine c'est au monde
france ce qu'ont bien c'est un chiffre
qui n'est pas actuellement rendus
publics mais ça fait l'objet de
discussions avec le csa mais rassurez
vous les moyens sont mis sur le marché
français pour que ça fonctionne mais
subissent par des français voici mais
subissent au fait monsieur tabaka mais
c'est le sénateur sur votre question sur
le sur le droit d'auteur
je crois qu'en effet on peut parler
d'une différence d'interprétation sur le
concept de droits d'auteur dans la
culture américaine et dans la culture
française
je vous la corde par contre sur le sujet
de ce qui se passe en france je les ai
évoqué dans mes propos préliminaires
d'abord sur le fait que nous avons des
accords avec la sacem va et cd d'ascama
madea gp et la sef qui montre vraiment
que nous prenons ce sujet au sérieux
de façon très large j'espère demain avec
la pique et d'autres dans le cadre des
discussions sur le droit voisin et sur
ce sujet là je reviens sur mon poids en
introduction mais qui était un point
vraiment important aujourd'hui est il
cependant ne les rapports que nous
aurons désert avec les eaux dans les
années à venir
kika la taille à laquelle on opère une
entreprise comme google a su mettre de
l'autonomie dans les différents pays
pour pouvoir nous adapter à ces règles
locales et le fait que nous signons ces
accords depuis des années sur le droit
d'auteur fait partie de notre mandat
fait partie de notre compréhension de ce
qui est unique à la france et c'est vrai
pour mes collègues qui sont amenés à
diriger un certain nombre d'autres pays
qui ont cette flexibilité pour ses
objectifs
pays par pays et je compléterai juste
sur la partie cloud pour répondre à
madame la sénatrice et de saillies sur
les questions du clad et notamment sur
le stockage des données
en fait pour nous on a une souveraine la
vision de la souveraineté en fait autour
du stockage des données
ça repose en trois piliers un pic sur
lui le stockage en fait la part dont la
souveraineté sur les données
c'est à dire avoir la capacité à un
client par exemple une entreprise de
décider du lieu du stockage de s'adonner
et ça c'est important c'est de dire où
est ce que m'a donné d'autres pièces
qu'elle peut être stockée en europe et
qu'en europe ou ailleurs ça c'est le
premier élément c'est quelque chose
qu'on offre en offre également la
capacité pour n'importe quel utilisateur
de chiffrer les données de
de pouvoir en fait les rendent
matériellement impossible d'accès par
nos équipes et ce chiffrement est géré
par des tiers extérieurs et par exemple
avec thales le deuxième élément le
deuxième niveau ça serait la
souveraineté qu'on va appeler
opérationnel s'est par exemple décider
de la nationalité des personnes qui vont
administrer le système c'est important
parce que madame morano s'est il a
rappelé des américains peuvent être
tentés de pouvoir avoir des échanges
avec telle ou telle autorité etc
on a la capacité au travers la
souverainté opérationnel de pouvoir
gérer ce point là est le deuxième point
qui la souverainté logiciel sébastien en
parler c'est le coeur de l'accord avec
ovh s'est véritablement de déconnecter
un certain nombre d'outils logiciels de
du réseau google et donc d'avoir en fait
c'est ce logiciel opéré par par ovh donc
ça c'est des choses sur lequel on croit
beaucoup et on pense que c'est la proche
à avoir madame morin desailly rappelé
effectivement les demandes fisas google
a été une des premières années une des
premières entreprises pensent gars
maintenant quasiment dix ans à se battre
et obtenir en justice la capacité de
pouvoir divulguer le nombre de demandes
fisas qu'on recevait de la part des
autorités américaines pour justement
créé cette transparence et anthony 10 et
le terme d' à comptabilité mais
véritablement cette logique où n'importe
qui peut savoir effectivement combien de
demandes sont adressées de la part des
autorités les concernant ou concernant
plus généralement de nos produits
merci messieurs pour les réponses à
apporter
je pense que nous aurons d'autres
occasions d'engager de continuer ce
dialogue avec vous dans cette commission
dans d'autres instances évidemment du du
sénat on est bien conscient les uns et
les autres que les sujets sur lequel
vous travaillez que nous devons
légiférer sont des questions complexes
qui renvoie à la fois des évolutions
technologiques mais aussi à des
questions de société qu'est le sur le
technologique bien sûr vous pouvez
répondre sur le quai sur le plan
sociétal c'est une responsabilité
partagée
je reprendrai le terme le mot confiance
utilisé par plusieurs d'entre vous je
crois qu'il est important pour établir
un un travail utile pour tous d
d'installer cette confiance et cette
confiance elle repose beaucoup on le
sait sur de la transparence
c'est pour ça que plus vous êtes précis
dans vos réponses plus c'est un moyen
pour nous de sentir la réalité de cette
confiance je reste un peu frustré du
fait que vous ne donniez pas le nombre
de modérateur en france parce que ça
nous donnerait une indication ne sont
pas qu'elle est une confidentialité mais
ça nous donnerait une indication un peu
plus précis sur la réalité de la
modération effectués sur sur sur votre
réseau social
merci de 2,7 de cet échange
[Musique]